Ross Tucker friend of the show works for
Westwood one is one of their football
analysts former NFL lineman the Ross
Tucker podcast works for a Sirius XM and
Ross will get to the controversial
Taylor Swift topic in a moment but if
Kansas City and San Diego played ten
times how many wins do you have for
Kansas City I love that you're still
calling on San Diego by the way Dan
yes about just about everybody's still
doing that it's hilarious I don't know
man based on last night
I'm thinking maybe five and five I'm
shocked okay that they won that game
last night Dan I mean Kansas City is the
loudest outdoor stadium I ever played in
that is a very very difficult place to
win especially in a night game I
remember playing there one time Dan it
was so loud I was backing up all three
spots I wanted no part of going in that
game whatsoever and for LA to do that
without their top two running backs and
to not have Keenan Allen in the second
half it's unbelievably impressive it's
kind of a shame that the Chargers lost a
Fritz's Bronco is a few weeks ago and
they still don't have the number one
seed or the AFC West right now as a
result you know that sheaf still control
their own destiny but it was a really
really impressive win and I'm thrilled
for guys like Philip Rivers Antonio
Gates even Anthony Landon we started our
own for was looking rough and now he's
20 and six in his last 26 games who's
your favorite in the AMC right now I'm
still gonna go with the Chiefs because I
think it helps when they get Eric Barry
back I like what I saw from their young
running backs last night and you have to
go through Kansas City as of right now
now that Seattle game next Sunday
becomes gigantic obviously because they
need to try to get home-field advantage
it's unbelievable to me Dan with the
Chargers and the Chiefs the difference
between winning that division or not I
mean you talked about the number one
seed and two home games you're on a
Super Bowl or three away
games and I think it's crazy about the
NFL ban we might have talked about
earlier in the year but if you would ask
me certainly four or five weeks ago I
would said Dan there's only four teams
that can realistically go to Super Bowl
and the NFC it's the Saints in the Rams
and the AFC it's the Chiefs and the
Patriots and now I don't feel that way
anymore now I can see a three four five
or six seed making it run in either
conference I think it's a lot more wide
open than we thought
the MVP right now is still going mahomes
but Ruth it's close you know he didn't
really mean to play bad last night but
he didn't he didn't take it you know and
run away with it last night I was saying
Brees earlier but mahomes had a couple
of ridiculous games and Brees had been a
little quiet the last few weeks and now
Rivers is throwing his hat in the ring I
think kind of like the Heisman how Kyler
Murray finished so strong
and to uh did not and I ended up getting
getting Kyler the Heisman I think that's
how the MEP gonna be I think these last
three weeks are gonna determine the MVP
and that those three guys are kind of
neck and neck I think it's probably
mahomes
by a nose still right now but I think
that can change based on what happens
these next couple weeks yeah I think
quarterback who wins his division in the
AFC West is gonna be your MVP
I don't think breezes put up good enough
numbers he had the rough outing against
the Cowboys on national TV they're a
little bit more of a run first team now
I still you know the Chargers with
breeze and mahomes if he throws for
fifty five touchdown passes I think it
comes down to who wins that division
you might be right I know breeze plays
Monday night against Carolina so he has
a chance to put up big numbers but you
know if we've learned anything Dan it's
how you finish really really matter even
like you know these coaches that might
get fired or not you know these last
three games it means it means a lot I've
been on teams where we finished strong
and the coach saved his job I've been on
teams where you know we lost the last
three and the guy got fired how you
finish even if you think it's a lost
season matters and Drew Brees is not
finishing as strong as he needs to right
now to win the MVP like I thought he was
going to you all win on the Cowboys as
one of the two or three best teams in
the NFC if I put the Saints in the Rams
or the Rams in the Saints where do the
Cowboys fit in there I still probably
put them four or five right now I'd go
Saints one Rams two Bears three and then
Cowboys in Seattle are actually pretty
close in my mind I think because of what
they got going with Amari Cooper I think
I'd go Dallas for Seattle five but
that's going to be an epic wildcard game
and that's going to be the the Sunday
night you know NBC game or whatever you
know that game between the Cowboys and
the Seahawks should be amazing should be
in my mind clearly the best game of
wildcard weekend it's looking like
that's how it's gonna unfold he's Ross
Tucker he works for Westwood One he is
going to be working Texans and the Jets
coming up this weekend for Westwood One
but you had a tweet yesterday a music
statement yesterday that frankly I
thought maybe Paulie was fooling me and
pulling my leg that you you sent out a
tweet and you backed it up and you
firmly believed in it so let the
audience know what your tweet was well
just to give some background Dan okay
yesterday was Taylor Swift's birthday
she does by the way happened to be from
my hometown of Wyomissing Pennsylvania
so I might be a little bit by isn't
there so on my radio show we were
playing all Taylor Swift music and one
of my listeners knows that I happen to
think that Prince's music will
overrated so he tweeted me and said mmm
you like this stuff but you don't like
prints and I said you know don't compare
Taylor Swift to prints I think Taylor
Swift has 10 songs that are better than
any apprentice songs and then it did not
go over real well
I got eviscerated on social media and
people are telling me well Prince plays
26 instruments plaits you know Prince
had his own genre
he changed the culture look then I don't
care how many instruments he plays I'm
not comparing the two as musicians I
know he wrote nothing compares you for
Shane O'Connor I'm talking about their
songs and all I care about
not John resort alter or how
sophisticated you sound I all I care
about is how the music sounds when it
goes through my ears into my brain and
I'm telling you there's at least five
Taylor Swift's arms that I'd rather
listen to than any Prince home I mean
what's his best song Dan Purple Rain is
that like that's a greater Purple Reign
purple is that good where is that good
when is that song good I mean raspberry
beret that's okay I actually like little
red Corvette but I'd still take five
Taylor Swift songs over them I'm
standing by I like her music more did
anybody threaten you did the reaction
get that bad I got a lot of threats yeah
I got a lot of people a lot of people
actually reported me to Twitter as spam
suspicious evidently I got a lot of
people threatening me with violence and
you know my favorite is all the people
then telling me to you know turn in my
man card
that's the joke of it to me is that I
think a lot of people I think a lot of
people say they like Prince because they
think it makes them sound sophisticated
or you know more artsy more cultured and
they don't want to admit that they like
Taylor swear
because it's teeny bopper in their mind
teeny bopper high school girls or
whatever but I think deep down in places
that some people like don't want to
admit I think that they love Taylor
Swift's music and I think that when they
get in the car and they're driving
they'd rather have one of her awesome
songs come on then Purple Rain Purple
Rain and people threatening violence to
me is hilarious because you know what
I'll do then I'll come to their house
and I'll put Taylor Swift on my boombox
and I'll punch him in the face and I'll
beat them up while Taylor Swift music is
playing in the background how about that
for my man card what would be the song
oh man there's so many good ones bad
blood I mean if I'm going to get to
fight with somebody bad blood
well good luck going outside today Ross
that's Ross Tucker safe travels Texans
Jets coming up Saturday Westwood one
he's Ross Tucker the Ross Tucker podcast
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]